a tutti almeno di solito sono amica e
oggi andremo a vedere delle cose un po
particolari e ma andremo a vedere delle
cose scioccanti trovate nei nostri cibi
preferiti o mesi in generale i cibi
preferiti delle persone da paura per
avere anche paura perché poi mi viene
fame a me quindi il mio maggiore tutto
ma non sono molto belle regate che
devono vedere ma io so comunque allora
prendete i pop corn e se volete
raccontarci le commesse mi è mai
successo di trovare qualcosa di strano
nel cibo scrivetecelo nei commenti siamo
curiosi di vedere come cosa vi è
capitato di trovare preferivo cara
lasciate un bel legga questo video e
iniziamo subito way
vediamo cosa hanno trovato al tavolo con
gli uomini
sapete che saab uefa i pani lecce italia
sabri credo di si fa i pani to buy e gli
dissi solo il mare né in queste sere con
quattro ingredienti o 5 su tutti quello
che banale cosa era un coltello un
coltello c'è altro volto nel panino un
coltello ma possibile
ha fatto il panino e poi si è
dimenticato dentro così è andata
volontario chissà pure addio
no mi sembra strano perché di solito
panamera e se fai il sabot lungo voto
votando no a metà prima di d'arte loro
che a me piacciono tantissimo quindi un
paura di quello che sto per vedere
il progetto spiaccicato nella crema
allora no no no io sono anche megan i
nove sale aprirai sempre proprio della
succede pure tagliente no vabbè ma
possibile che pensava detto forse erano
scaduti boh spero che sia perché erano
scaduti sono per questo però è terribile
ovvio dio immagina se non so come ha
fatto la concezione questa persona l'ha
aperta e controllato perché forse come
te li a breve poi leccare la crema 3
invece di marzo direttamente tali così
io avrei mangiato tutto
immagino che tu dai un morso e poi non
lo so ti veniva di dubbio sentivo sapore
force tra aprile
ma io non metto il ragno io non lo avrei
comitato avrei fatta voi come avreste
reagito se avete trovato un ragno nei
vostri oreo a forino taglio
ah ecco qua meglio la foto allora gli ex
brawn di mcdonald's di casa fa quindi
non di patate e ci forse è un po di
tutto insomma questa brutta spese brutto
forte mi sento male
oh mio dio trasmessa già morso quindi
magari era dentro la bustina e lui stava
mangiando così prendete un importanza di
accendere le luci nemici mangia perché
non sparare al buio
ogni volta che andremo mezz'ora
ispezionate ben cibo fast food mai
spettinate bene se no va beh voi come
avreste reagito io avrei mai più
mangiatori mai più grave grave carenza
di gen addio a questo cos'è una blatta
una scarpa mi sembra fatta poverino
il proprio stato cucinato capito non è
che dici vabbè calato di dopo che ne so
ma grido di a giocare è stato cucinato
sia quello croccante pensionati insieme
alla brawn
[Musica]
[Applauso]
basta sta avvenendo forti e passata non
vedendo quello che ho più ma favori
omogeneizzate con il tacchino e facchino
fatto
cos'è un destro o mio dio è praticamente
hanno trovato un pezzo di vetro dentro
l'omogeneizzato non so non ho capito se
bambino aveva messo in meno però quando
se ne sono accorti gli avevano tolto lo
diceva che in altri trenta stati degli
stati uniti sono stati trovati della
stessa marca dei prezzi di vetro in
questione
mio zio in irlanda c'è in italia non so
se c'è però insomma tutti il cioccolato
in irlanda non sono buoni per niente
sono super stuker all phillips e non
hanno proprio un buon sapore quindi
questa è una specie di corretta di maro
però non buono
vediamo cosa è stato trovato dentro non
si è capito sarà un dente che ha trovato
dentro la barretta che gli si è staccato
un dente
niente di piacevole comunque allora
dentro il gelato che consentono alla
meta di quelle dei taglierini ha trovato
una lametta nel gelato prima era
avvertibile che finiscano a destra forse
nella fabbrica poi superstrada
vediamo ho paura ho paura sono una donna
ho trovato un cerotto con versando e sto
proprio questo sporco dentro le catene
di mcdonalds sicuramente chi stava
preparando tutto dall'amaro grave è
deliziosa devo dire che quindi
rigenerino o qualcosa di una zampetta di
un'era la band ovale come possibile
dentro un gelato forse era un reparto
surgelati si sono confusi hanno messo le
rane dentro i gerarchi gelati dentro le
rane malarazza che fanno entrambe le
cose ma se uno fa isolati in un fan che
regalano magari partito o dentro al
caffè sembra un commessi come rio che
tristezza
mamma mia auto finivano dentro che
triste non mi dire te l'avevo già
sentita che avevano trovato un verme nei
ferrero rocher abbiamo questo possibile
che sia entrato dopo quando tu l'hai
comprato lo porti a casa poi magari
rientra dopo non è che stai a trani
una carta che scava nella carta addio
vabbè controllate sempre le date di
scadenza
a me è successo con i fichi secchi
in pratica erano scaduti mi sembra però
non c'è la data di scadenza perché sono
fatti a mano sono fichi erano previste
chi quelli che gli altri dentro c'è la
mano di stato per mangiarlo stato per
lanciarlo poi non lo so come come
involontariamente forza vorrei mangiare
la mandorla infatti apriamolo o per sera
piero erano un minuscolo piccoli numero
uno dei pallini bianchi infatti
all'inizio questo bocca ti sei mai lo
scrivo perché io guardate bene né visti
né si muovevano ma se penso che l'avrei
potuto viaggiare a paio di occhiali e
che stasera sarà mola è la signora
anziana che stanno facendo al pane vino
chiarissimo non trovo gli occhiali
vabbè informiamo questo nonostante sia
chiaro un bellissimo allora questo non
riesco a capire forse questo più che
cose strane trovata nel cibo e cibo
strano perché è un panino con i muse
networks spaghetti asiatici con cotone
uno scotto lette un nuovo
a mangiare questa roba la mia è
decisamente passato l'appetito non
voglio più pranzare 9 che schifo
spero spero che sia appunto perché com'è
possibile che trovi un pollice umano
nella zuppa o poi le foto così non
scappi via a il titolo dice cose comuni
trovate nel cibo ma come c'è così tanto
e poi c'è qua sono state messe a fortuna
è questo qua però potrebbe
effettivamente essere un qualcosa che è
finito dentro burrito per sbaglio anche
perché qua dice così di un telegiornale
quindi sicuramente questo si è successo
davvero
potevi morire alla fine perché se te lo
dico io prometto di pezzi quanto detto è
un muffin chiara tutto ha fatto del cane
qualche canino quel senso di due blue
barry coates sembrava un bocca e naso
quando le cose nel cibo
mantenetevi magica e fagioli nella
copertina del cd ma perché perché perché
[Applauso]
non so se ho capito bene come direbbe sì
vi avevo già visto tempo fa e sono
rimasta scioccata
c'è una rana dentro lista alta com'è
possibile
33 chiusa sigillata c'è sicuramente la
roma avrà avuto da mangiare ma non in
genova lario per girare persone abbiamo
trovato poi l'abbia liberata in qualche
bel laghetto e abbia buttato via
l'insalata o dalla bela tarr infatti
mazzarri ma c'è un'altra foto l'accaduto
questo è un altro non so se un'altra i
party a guardarla santino questa
misticanza oddio di testa dall'altro se
ogni cosa che comprate l'insalata
prendiamo nella busta controllate bene e
ci è capitato di trovare brass qualche
lumachina prima non in quella imbustata
è fatto male vuol dire che vieterà le
mie cose trovate il rumor indiziata non
lo uccidete liberatele pure mettetele
fuori in giardino nelle aiuole così
possono continuare a vivere per ora non
so cosa sia questa cosa ma qualsiasi
cosa sia
mi fa paura o ibridi che cos'è un ragno
non c'è non lo so c'è una lattina e
dentro cos'è una tarantola
ma non si capisce se comunque che cosa
scrivete nei commenti però la paura c'è
scritto
cibo strano ho trovato in russia se
siete rossi o avete condiscendenza russa
di tesi che cibo ecco un bel burger ha i
capelli come proposto da qualcuno sono
combinazioni di cibo molto strane cioè
mangiare un hot dog con la banale ma
ormai non sembrano sbocciare
magari si può anche stare la banale ma
perché lo so però si impara però la
banana split ad esempio buonissima si
ragionava durata del lato la cia al
cioccolato si sa come la banana thatcher
che sai come sono gli americani per una
mamma ma sto sulla pizza è quindi magari
campana al posto dello tokyo
altra combinazione strana italiano e
fragole pancakes anche mammetti fu una
minestra perché stanno in mezzo
boh sono galleggiando un po no diciamo
che sono posti che noi non siamo anti
grassi folla poi mezzo ma perché tra
l'altro questi sono i piatti che
separano le cose vedi quindi se volevano
fare prima il pranzo i fagiolini e poi
il dessert panchen ma bisognava metterli
season ma in un piatto che separa se ne
va nella tra i due piatti diversi
avvocati non può che tenterà di tattica
ha fatto un cappuccino e dentro un
avvocato come paolo gallo realtà stadi
curioso di provarla con un birdie scusa
così zucchero per metterla se poi lo
zucchero
vabbè senza zucchero prima
sarei proprio curioso di provarlo perché
ci piacciono un sacco di avocado allora
qua hanno trovato un l'acciaio nel
panino nel burger
[Musica]
oddio puoi farti veramente male un
cucchiaio a trovare nel mag l'anm che
oppure nel pane cassetta si dimenticano
non sono gli occhiali ma anche cucchiai
appoggiato da scivolato e un attimo che
succedono queste cose poteva accorgere
ovviamente quando lo taglia di circa che
cosa questo lei in questo caso questo
che te ne accorgi già prima della pizza
che punta rifà cos'è questa cosa un
hamburger nera un'auto da meri fini
ragazzi mi è bastato anche a me lo ha
passato ha potuto acquistare questo
concludiamo il video con un cibo
buonissimo l'avvocato è tra l'altro
questo è un ottimo sistema per togliere
la parte centrale è l'avvocato una volta
che lo taglia a metà
e lui il nocciolo che è bello grosso lo
estrae facilmente ne vado a fare da
costringere disastro e coleen perché se
non vi potete vi potreste tagliare
sapere se avete mai mangiato l'avvocato
il buonissimo con un po di sale e pepe
un po d'olio e purissimo comunque non
percorre la cosa che mi ha scioccato più
di tutte a me dopo annegato nel caveau
le mail ma aspetta quello di mcdonald la
brawn con l'inzio
che cosa mi ha scioccato di più falsetto
a fare nei commenti di sapere anche
altri video qui volete che in realtà ho
altre cose che volete cui reagiamo e ora
vi lasciamo pro 4 castellina su cui
cliccare per vedere i nostri altri video
cliccate su quella che preferite